starting your professional life isn't
easy when you lack experience best
parantha wanna know gossip you know k9k
para ver la Paris pelvic IdeaScale me
sir madam en no tengo tantas pnina
professional a la mejor dentro de campo
anything gonna toast Campos knows
quality color tackling this problem
head-on is the aim of the Youth
Employment initiative an eu-wide
financial instrument that provides
support to young people living in
regions with high youth unemployment
since 2013 this instrument has funded
youth employment provisions like
apprenticeships and traineeships it
supports job placements and helps
Europeans under 25 in need of
qualification to further their education
the aim is to act within four months of
ending their studies or becoming
unemployed the European Parliament is
now pushing for innovative ways to
create jobs promote long-term employment
for the young and drive policy change
across Europe
providing opportunities and hope for its
youth is an existential challenge for
the EU as a whole